[Music]
in the DreamWorks Dragons franchise the
dragons are Fantastical bees found in a
region of the world known as the
barbaric archipelago they are powerful
reptiles known for their ability to fly
and produce fire although not every
dragon can do both and some have neither
fire nor flight but rather they possess
obscure and curious abilities they come
in all shapes and sizes with a multitude
of species each different from the other
and yet sharing a similar lineage which
brings us to the question what are their
real Origins to get to the answer we
must first take a look at where they are
found and their history in that
place so this brings us to the barbaric
archipelago which is a group of 70 or
more islands and even smaller Isles
spread out in between this is the
setting for the Viking sea kingdoms and
Villages seen in the dragons franchise
the exact location of this place is
between Greenland and the Norwegian Seas
so dragons there and people have been at
odds for countless of years and they
have battled one another with every
single chance they get until Hiccup and
the Night Fury called toothless brought
about a new peace this tells us that the
dragons have been in and around these
Seas for hundreds of years meaning that
they have evolved and diversified in the
barbaric archipelago probably earlier
than even humans made landfall in the
islands
there in the original book series by
cesa Cowell the dragons have a mystical
origin they are not explained through a
scientific or biological perspective but
rather as creatures with a long history
on the islands where the story takes
place the dragons in the books are
portrayed as ancient and magical beings
that have coexisted with Vikings for
centuries in the How to Train Your
Dragons film franchise the dragons are
said to have originated from a mystical
place place called The Hidden World this
is a secret a well-conceived place where
dragons live and Nest safely in How to
Train a Dragon the Hidden World the
third and final installment of the film
series released in 2019 it is revealed
that the hidden world is the ancestral
home of the Dragons their place of
Origins the entrance to the hidden world
is through a Caldera which is a gigantic
collapsed volcano in the middle of the
ocean and the only way to enter the
Caldera is by flying in on a dragon and
dropped there and it was impossible for
humans to reach on their own the hidden
world is a vast and beautiful
underground realm that is a sanctuary
for Dragons allowing them to live away
from the conflicts with humans the film
explores the idea that dragons as a
species were drawn to the Hidden World
to protect themselves from Human
persecution the concept of the Hidden
World becomes a central theme in the
third movie as Hiccup and Toothless try
to find a new home for Dragons where
they can live peacefully and free from
from the threats posed by Dragon Hunters
which leads them to their original home
so in the context of the films the
dragon's Origins is associated with the
hidden world and it plays a crucial role
in the conclusion of the trilogy this
concept is unique to the Cinematic
adaptation and differs from the more
mystical and less defined Origins
presented in gra cow's original book
series the dragons however in the books
are considered to be a part of the
natural order of the world in which the
stories are set they are depicted as
diverse species with unique
characteristics and their existence is
deeply intertwined with the history and
culture of the Viking communities
portrayed in the books unlike the films
however there is no mention of a hidden
world or a central Source from which all
dragons originate from rather they are
like any other animal groups which have
evolved and speciated over the span of
millions of years so this place the
hidden world is set within a massive
volcanic caldera serving as a portal to
an intricate Maze of Chambers and
Volcanic tubes beneath the earth's crust
this Subterranean World features
bioluminous and fungi coral and
scintillating crystals creating a
visually stunning environment waterfalls
and pools on Coral shelves are form by
water seeping through the cracks in the
crust with heated water turning into
steam creating a tropical atmosphere the
hidden world is accessible through a
collapsed volcano in the ocean called
the Caldera which then can only be
entered by flying in on a dragon the
Calera leads to NW work of caves deep in
the Earth's crust eventually reaching
the mushroom Forest characterized by
stalactites and stalagmites covered in
various mushrooms the King Island is
located at the center of the Hidden
World serving as the throne room for the
king of dragons which was the Night Fury
uh Toothless and in that place is the
alpha Stone being a gigantic Crystal
overlooking a significant portion of
that Hidden World the place is further
explored and expanded in the Animated
Series dragons the nine Realms whereby a
comet came too close to the earth and
its gravitational anomaly opened a new
passage to the Hidden World called the
cison Fisher and in the course of the
series they liken it to the nine Realms
of Norse Legends so while are these nine
Dragon Realms there the first to be
described and seen is the crystal realm
accessible through the CIS and fissure
created by the comet it features
intricate crystalline structures
connected by caves and underground Lakes
it is a stable habit for the title class
dragons due to its huge and large water
sources next is the fire realm which is
characterized by molten lava and diverse
rock formations the fire realm is
hazardous and has extreme temperatures
dragons like the catastrophic quens
construct nests within large formations
in the stretcher environment then next
we have the ice realm which is a
consistently cold environment with snowy
Landscapes blizzards and unique crystals
that sustain vegetation despite being
deep on the the ground it supports a
variety of Flora and a shimmering Aurora
boreales then next we have the nature
realm boasting abundant vegetation
towering trees and carnivorous plants
with thick Vines it provides nesting
habitats for Dragon species like the
sniffle Heights and Vine trails and many
others then we come to The King's Realm
which is an expansive mountainous region
with diverse topography featuring
towering Peaks rugged Cliffs and a lush
environment rich in ancient energy it
has become a Beacon of Hope for Dragons
seeking an ideal habitat the sixth here
is the giant realm which has a temperate
climate supporting giant grasses
resembling trees and providing ample
hiding places it Harvest some of the
largest known Dragon species and
includes a vast sea with tial class
dragons in it then next we have the
desert realm featuring a vast desert
with glass structures created by glass
casts it is distinct with black sand
instead of yellow sand and offers a
unique landscape within the Hidden World
so those are the Seven Realms firstly
and now the eighth realm is called the
Dark Realm which is a swampy area with
thick fogs and red dragon site
illumination it houses dangerous
predators and it is called the
underworld of that region it is a baron
section with Crystal Hills Vapors and
minimal water sources it is also home to
the yman Gander which is termed as the
world serpent but in reality was just
another gigantic Serpentine Dragon
species but then again it is the
ultimate predator of all dragons then
lastly we have something which is called
the biorem which is cavernous with
bioluminous and mushrooms and crystals
it hosts a symbiotic relationship
between crystals and animals and surface
dwelling trees also extend their Roots
deep into its local it might also be the
entrance into the other Realms through
the
Caldera so this is all that we have
about the origins of the dragons and the
Realms of the Hidden World anyway if you
like this video then check this other
one as well and if you're more
interested in other movie monsters and
creatures then take a look at our
Channel we have a lot of things that you
might haven't seen before like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next one take
care fam